love cloud is a romantic airline here
located in las vegas nevada
we do specific and romantic flights for
couples
three being wedding flights romantic
dinner flights
but the most important and the most
popular are
mile high club flights
[Music]
i first came up with the idea in college
as a joke i thought hey this would be
such a cool idea to do something like
this
we plan for this to be a large business
in itself
that is unique that no one else has ever
done in the world
welcome to the love cloud thank you are
you guys excited
yes awesome we've got a beautiful day i
actually was scrolling through tik tok
on one of my super late night couldn't
sleep adventures
and i saw it and i knew we were coming
to vegas so once i saw it on tick tock i
messaged him immediately and i was like
we
have to go on this flight i was like i
saw it and there was no way we were
going to come here and i couldn't
do it and this is your special trip we
want to make sure that you guys have
full excitement and fun and privacy will
be
borrowed people coming to us from
different countries wanting to do
interviews wanting to do
different articles on us because it is
taboo but it is something that's on a
lot of people's mind
we really bring couples together in a
way that
uh it's a romantic experience where we
have really helped couples reconnect
now that i've been through it i i would
honestly do it
yeah i was very private too so there was
nowhere never any kind of awkwardness
between
us and the crew they didn't ask any
kind of questions or anything then they
definitely gave us as much privacy as
they absolutely could